Olympian ryan lochte is used to intense
training so will that make him a front
runner to win it all in the Battle of
the Olympians we're betting on gymnast
Lori Hernandez she and partner Val
Chmerkovskiy are already looking strong
in rehearsals vows biggest competition
maybe his brother Max who's paired with
TV personality Amber Rose Amber's no
stranger to shake and water mama gave
her and the season 18 mirror ball champ
may be the perfect partner to help her
hone her skills we are having way too
much little woman la start our Jolie
spears in the past so expect pro partner
Sasha to capitalize on that former NFL
star Calvin Johnson was known for his
touchdown dances but so far is keeping
his practices with pro Lindsay Arnold
closed and away from la in Michigan
Jenna were shirt look what it says
that's love right there but Disney star
jake t austin and partner jenna johnson
are flaunting their teamwork he's 21 and
it's her first year as a pro while
rookie mistakes may be expected they're
predicting a win through it all the way
they'll have tough competition with
these two our team name is glamour Wow
go glamour have it so much fun country
singer Jana Kramer's backstory will get
viewers attention ET broke the news the
new mom split with her husband of just
over a year he's now in rehab she's
paired with returning pro gleb savchenko
and tonight ET is breaking news about y
pro Mark Ballas won't be in the ballroom
after 18 straight seasons the former
champ step it away from the show to take
over a lead role in the Broadway show
Jersey bullets
you